co2 з фільму харківських школі rifle у
такий спосіб дати це класний тип
валерія to wear а ви вирішила рустави
Прагнемо ситуації про ситуацію в Україні
настрій людей інформативну провину табу та
на донбасі дівчатам bridge to the
журналістка ми їх теж дуже
харківських шкулів запити долонею берга
для u-6 у баварському форумі шкіл юнеско
то дискусіях освічених Україні
школярик ділиться та зведу я газу і ти
правду інформативний провини
дорожче харкер ських школярик та не
машини вид bull ася в рамках партнерства
mist проти вас 20 5 руки в sfiv брати
тут народи лось від шуму луз пильних
проекті культурних щодо соціальних анти
rmp називають фарбовану багатів злих яко
про коди стукнеш харковому то
нюрнбергом ринку важливо жити за
ситуацію в Україні проти якщо а пудель
на Майдані
антипу металу що німці не забуду
розуміти, що сама в Україні забувайте
скептик у не менше немає вже добрі змій
і багато добрих грунтових матеріалів про
україну а ви їй дуже багато так їх хто
так би міг ці тенденції нас пряма
україну я до бійки в лівий головний в ик-6
на безтурботне шоу руїну і чудово у явно не
про мер у Європі і багато так їх тас
пряма путіна деталі серйозні путін
вагою для ансат зуміємо абизів вбивши
чому анти судно думати а ми за початку
валу в образі традиції круглих столик
для обміну думка ми Торін формування
німців в одному усних владний взяв і
доля харківський школяр люди і ті ж
видав і каменяки украй на може на так
він у нас пробивається ми хотіли б раз
повісті правду ще молячись правді вид
чого йому одна тисяча викладається
потала бездоріжжя в інтернеті в газетах
про тілам кілька гудим школі вірус
побачила ним team крута де пропаганда
на воду ви приклади маніпуляції вузли як
російських
українських сара тих хто прийшов за слухом
до українських дітей bull і таких-то
вперше пучків про інформативний і
на школу шляху та в Україні а я тут ною
бізона мозес на тася ще нічого проц вона
читала теж жадібно ягідки на моє
а кликаний від нас же раз побачив і процес
школі за собою масової інформації
чищення може маніпулювати людьми алое
тепер ми побачили yax цем на пряму ось
ці консультанти людям в Україні
реакція вже по суті стала їхньою ним по всій
дані
залу хитайся безуважно мною історії
молодих архіві on на чоловікові його гості
розплавив і про на айстру та в Україні
проблеми переселенців піди на донбасі
павидлу не провини у мирному харкові
атмосфера на я мірного місця хоч я не
мобільні нашого місці алое ми не знаємо
ще року сьогодні-завтра божий завтра
буде і рядок цінний з не страшнішим ти
не знаєш я буду завтра саровського
розумінням і моєму страх напарник це
вдома страх того, що ми повернемо осі і
будуть нас вина я навіть поважаючого ціни
його жінки я проблеми тихого сифон
detour сповідаюсь що одужай
навчилася у по ну ось і свої почуття так
критично ставлять і сяду інформація до
ширші за ці
поправочку ситуації в Україні он з
повними оптимізму вивела про раджу
осі будинку
поспіль та завдяки rush не прогрілася ми
пропадала собі те святе місце кайфовала
а десятка мороки скажіть мені я кощія
окраїна вища за місяць від роботи
армію і ми розробити у вірмен з вікна
держави з лютера жертвувала
а на благо день є це перший крок якщо
у падику сталося причастя провини
ми
навчилася про розум ти сильний стребкова
жити а сам із цього приводу савони буревич
зазвичай вина як наш краще потім шилася а